après avoir entendu beaucoup de bien du
film roma de netflix
ces deux cinéphiles ont voulu le voir
sur grand écran impossible on pensait
qu'on peut rien à voir ce soir mais
malheureusement c'est complet cette
histoire d'une famille de classe moyenne
à mexico dans les années 70 affiche
complet jusqu'au 6 janvier dans la seule
petite salle indépendante a présenté
roman à montréal le film du géant
américain est d'abord et avant tout
destiné à sa plateforme numérique le
cinéma moderne pour montréal devient une
forme de fenêtres de promotion ça permet
d'avoir des textes dans les journaux ça
permet d'être à la télévision va porter
une certaine attention et maintenant si
vous voulez le voir mais vous devrez
aller sur meetic
ah non vous n'êtes pas abonné c'est
dommage en privilégiant un visionnement
à la maison ou sur un appareil mobile
netflix s'attaque aux modes de
distribution des films et aux circuits
conventionnels des salles de cinéma ça
ébranle toute la chaîne de production et
de de mise en marché des films
totalement et ça brouille complètement
jeu de ce qui était effectivement la
façon de lancer les films peu comme
netflix en fait à brouiller les cartes
du côté de la télévision
en plus de rom a qualifié de
chefs-d'oeuvre par les critiques
le géant a aussi mis la main sur le
nouveau film des frères coen
je préférerais ne pas avoir à les jouer
ça change tout vous savez le plus
important c'est la capacité de produire
un film si jamais j'ai une histoire qui
intéresse notre flic s'est connecté
s'est intéressée à le produit c'est
certain que ça fait partie maintenant
d'une avenue absolument possible pour
que nos films soient vus sur la planète
avec environ 137 millions d'abonnés
netflix est là pour rester et un autre
géant amazon vu aussi distribuer ses
propres films nos habitudes de
consommation sont en pleine mutation
le cinéma aujourd'hui c'est aussi
netflix
on ne peut on n'y peut rien on peut
pleurer on peut protester mais la
réalité est là
quant à nos deux cinéphiles ils ont
trouvé des billets pour voir roma ce
grand écran mais à une date ultérieure
pas question pour eux de voir un tel
film à la maison moi ça m'intéresse pas
tellement netflix
puis j'ai pas les grands écrans chinois
n'ont pas encore mais temps
ici gouiffé dépouillé mais radio-canada
mots rien